[Musique]
car au nom plus de 4000 pages à lire en
deux mois cette seconde du lycée de la
plaine de neauphle ne chôme pas depuis
la rentrée elle participe au prix
découvre des lycéens avec leur
professeur de lettres
pour une fois la lecture ça sort du
cadre scolaire de la lecture analytique
de lecture linéaire des commentaires
proposés tout ça c'est autre chose
l'idée c'est de ses de retrouver une
forme de liberté par rapport au livre
parce que parce que souvent il est vécue
dans la scolarité comme étant une forme
de contrainte
le 15 novembre un lauréat recevra le
prix avant il faut lier découvert de
nouvelles techniques de lecture échanges
avec leurs professeurs et organisations
de l'emploi du temps puis surtout
mercredi après midi parce qu'on a on n'a
pas cours le samedi aussi dimanche du
cousin promet week-end mais c'est pas
grave c'est qu'on aura fini bon sera
content
je me suis relié avec eux mon bon mon
camarade en groupe de deux ans on dit
d'y vivre les quinze livres ton lit pas
comme si on lisait un livre normalement
en fait on y on y vite et on saute d on
peut sauter des paragraphes ou des
passages des pages pour les aider dans
leurs choix les 30 trappistes ont pu
rencontrer les auteurs durant une
journée sur paris ils ont pu poser des
questions lors de conférences d'enrichir
ma culture déjà le savoir aussi du coup
quand je lis un lit je me poserai
différentes questions des questions que
j'ai pas forcé que ne suis pas forcément
posée avant j'ai trouvé ça intéressant
parce qu'on pouvait voir leurs esprits
en fait ce qu'ils pensaient vraiment en
écrivant leurs livres et c'était
intéressant de jeu coup ça n'a rien à
voir avec les rencontres avec les
adultes ils sont beaucoup plus spontanée
il est vraiment ce qu'ils pensent encore
un mois de lectures avant de devoir
faire un choix avec le prix goncourt des
lycéens certains élèves ont renforcé
leur amour de la lecture d'autres l'ont
découvert